nuevas e inmensas ayudas en alemania
contra la subida de los precios el
gobierno invertirá 65 mil millones de
euros en una serie de medidas para
apoyar los ciudadanos a enfrentar la
inflación
el tercer paquete de ayuda
presupuestaria que hemos elaborado es
mayor que los dos primeros son 65 mil
millones de euros y son 95 mil millones
de euros si se tienen en cuenta los dos
primeros paquetes de ayuda esto es muy
importante es necesario y debe
contribuir a que los ciudadanos puedan
superar esta situación con nosotros el
mes pasado los precios volvieron a subir
en alemania un 79 por ciento debido al
aumento del costo de la energía a raíz
de la guerra en ucrania
en este contexto y para bajar los del
gas el canciller olaf scholz también
planea grabar los super beneficios de
las empresas energéticas
nos aseguraremos de que estos beneficios
excesivos no puedan seguir siendo
explotados grabando los de alguna manera
como es el caso del impuesto a las
energías renovables y utilizaremos los
muchos miles de millones que habremos
recaudado de esta manera para aliviar a
los ciudadanos poniendo un freno a los
precios de la electricidad
pero esta cuestión divide a la coalición
de gobierno los ecologistas y los
socialdemócratas quieren gravar los
miles de millones que ganan ciertos
grupos pero los liberales se oponen al
proyecto el gobierno ha decidido
finalmente abogar a nivel europeo por la
introducción de una contribución
obligatoria de las empresas energéticas
los estados miembros del bloque se
reunirán la próxima semana para debatir
el tema